hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast compete game status and
circulating tumor cells and tumor tissue
from mcrpc patients I am Brenda Kelly
Kim labyrinth and I'll be your moderator
for today's event today's webcast is
protected by laggards com competing
social media sites for science
professionals and sponsored by epic
science epic science is developing novel
Diagnostics to personalize and advance
the treatment and management of cancer
the epic sciences rare settle detection
platform can enable detection of genetic
and molecular changes in cancer
throughout a patient's journey for more
information please visit epic sciences
com before we start there are a few
instructions we want to hear from you
during this interactive broadcast so
please ask questions or leave us a
comment answers are welcome to you can
do this by hitting the green Q&A button
at the lower left of the presentation
window and typing in your comments and
questions we'll try to get to as many as
we can and will follow up with you if we
don't have time today want a better look
you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you can't hear or see this presentation
properly please let us know by clicking
on the support button on the top right
or use the Q&A button we'll make sure we
try to resolve any issues this webinar
has been approved for continuing
educational credit please click on the
CD button at the bottom left corner and
follow the process to receive your
credit now let's get right to today's
presenter we are proud to welcome dr.
Edith news month dr. Guzman is a
research scientist with solid academic
and industry background and cancer cell
biology and tumor metabolisms her
current work at genatech includes
developing oncology diagnostic
strategies that involve identification
and analysis of circulating tumor cells
dr. Guzman received her PhD from
technion-israel institute of technology
and holds a master's degree in
biochemistry from bison institute of
science dr Grossman please begin thank
you
that's good morning everybody I'm either
Schaffer Glickman I'm a principal
scientific researcher in the Department
of obedience apology biomarker
development at Genentech and I will
study today a lot about our studies on
the concordance of retention schedules
in circulating tumor cells in 16 and
tumor tissue from castration-resistant
prostate cancer patients I will start by
giving you a brief introduction to
prostate cancer I will then I tell you
by our interesting and I'll analyzing
city sees in prostate cancer and finally
I will walk you through our results of
the study of p10 status entities from
castration-resistant prostate cancer
prostate cancer is the most common
malignancy in males in Western countries
with an incidence of 62 new cases per
100,000 persons 30 years and it's the
third leading cause of cancer mortality
in Western countries now the majority of
the patient will be diagnosed with early
stage disease those patients were the
cancer recurrence bastard local
treatment are usually treated with
custard with castration or androgen
deprivation and although they initially
respond this is not curative and most
patients using very early progress to a
castration resistant disease I'm in this
setting the paralytic options are either
similarity with of attraction or a
second-line hormone therapy or
alternatively the patient can be
included Lineker trials for a new
therapies that target them so fast ways
that are involved in the progression
prostate cancer and and in this
particular thing understanding the
molecular characteristics of the
disease's progression will help select
the treatment and optimize therapy one
of the pathways that is frequently
activated in prostate cancer is pi/3
klkt pathway that regulates music
geological cell cycle processes
proliferation differentiation migration
and invasiveness metabolism angiogenesis
this post we can be activated you either
by a lot of people negative regulator by
mutations or by the loss of Latino by
epigenetic silencing or by a gain of
function of positive regulators like pi3
kinase kinase an 818 and the activation
of this pathway leads to chemoresistance
and cell survival so the effect of this
pathway your cone on cancer on console
survival basically positive that ATT
inhibition may be a beneficial treatment
for for cancer now in particular in
prostate one of the molecular mechanisms
of molecular events that leads very
frequently to activation of the akp
pathway is the loss of pten and this
evidence for this comes from from
clinical and preclinical observations in
mouse models the deletion of p10 is
associated with progression to
castration resistant revealed now
pretence also frequently lost in
prostate cancer and the loss of it and
converts poor prognosis in prostate
cancer now we can also play a role in
the revelation of a are finally
signaling and resistance to learn all
that you desire a negative feedback
feedback loop so there is a lot of
interest in graphic strategies that
combine inhibition of they are signaling
with AK p38 mascara fish and the
assessment of p10 with a promising
biomarker for difficulty targeted
therapies now in prostate in in
castration-resistant prostate cancer the
availability of tissues or diagnosis may
be limited first because of the long
time since the initial diagnosis to
through the evolution through
castration-resistant dismissed which can
take from 10 about 10 to 15 years second
because the often day the metastases are
exclusive to the bone and very difficult
to access and third because prostate
cancer is a heterogeneous disease even
the primary teacher can be often
multifocal and with different clones
evolving into different clinical courses
so the fifth to be a need for
alternative diagnostic modalities in
metastatic prostate cancer and liquid
biopsies can can help you can tell the
road in characterizing the metastatic
disease in Trafficante now the gold
standard for diagnosis has traditionally
been FFP issue that is harvested from
biopsy or surgery we took biopsies are a
non invincible or minimally invasive
methods to measure two more biomarkers
from a blood draw because diocese can
provide the current status of the
patient disease we can view them as a
snapshot of the biomarker profile of the
patient because I oh please cannot allow
for longitudinal monitoring and a
real-time assessment of divine martyr
status a liquid biopsy in particular
CDC's can help us capture clonality and
envision our national and help us
understand bc set originality and there
are many reasons then to analyze blood
for the current systemic disease now
although the prognostic value of City
generations has been very well
established in a large number of trials
and studies in particularly impressed in
prostrating learn what we are looking to
defend now is the molecular
characterization of species to get a
confession civ and continuous diagnostic
information the molecular
characterization of CTC such baseline we
can be predictable and can help us
understand
the patient will benefit from a
treatment then the molecular
characterization of TCC's during
treatment can help us understand whether
a patient is responding to the treatment
even before we have signals of clinical
response or whether there are signals
signs of molecular resistance and and
the assessment of ctcs at convention can
give us some hints into the mechanisms
into the molecular mechanisms of
resistance now one of the greatest
challenges in the analysis of CDC's
instead rarity in bladder this is why
the most traditional CTC detection
methods start by step of enrichment and
this is episode Richmond is followed by
the identification of CDC's original
strategies are based mostly on
biological properties like affinity or
physical properties like size or density
and then the identification of
difficulties in the pool often reached
glad is typically done using you know
cytochemistry or even a fluorescence or
rt-pcr for particular two more two more
relevant antigen now the platform that
we used in this work epic scientist got
for me is different from the most
traditional platforms in that is
enrichment free all the nucleated cells
that are present in ten milliliters of
blood will be plated into a series of
slides between 10 to 20 slides a nice
feature of this system is that we can
for instance all those lights for future
analysis now for the identification of
ctcs the slide will be stored and
staying with antibodies a and
cytokeratin g45 and debbie and there is
still a course channel of course open
channel for your favorite auntie cutting
and then the identification of the
disease is strong automated and it's
based on the detection of ctcs that I
hydrocracking for 5345 negative and a
positive plus and number
morphological features and this overview
really main workflow on that platform
leads directly to ctc enumeration now
the epic platform has capabilities for
molecular characterization but not only
City see enumeration and here we see
some of them on the upper right hand
right corner we see the isolation of
single City finish for genomic
characterization for copy number
variations and the analysis of variance
on the bottom left side we see the
analysis of protein biomarkers and using
the first channel that I mentioned
before the fourth local channel and on
the bottom right corner we see the
analysis of gene rearrangements
amplification for deletions using
fluorescence in situ hybridization now
here at didn't like we have extensive
experience using the sulfur system for
ctc enumeration and we have used the
solar system on a large number of
patients from clinical trial now in
comparison with the enumeration using
the epic science this platform and here
the invitation the numbers for the attic
platform were provided as by epic so we
see that it appears diabetic platform
captures that identifies more secrecy
from the soul search platform the
difference between the platform's you
said the solfege platform is the most
studied like one of the most traditional
platforms in vast use an enrichment step
to capture epithelial city sees a guy at
can possibly and now back to the numbers
into the epic platform captures more CD
series and this is particularly strong
in the case of non-small cell lung
cancer here at the bottom where
the salford chat forum only identified
CDC's more than one city fifteen thirty
three percent of the samples versus
sixty-eight percent of the samples in
the epic scientist platform now for our
study of the p10 status in city chiefs
from castration-resistant consultation
we collaborated with a group of or Johan
de Bono identical cancer research at the
UK and with epic science is to first
develop an essay to detect feet and lost
in cities in prostate cancer and then to
evaluate the concordance of feet and
loss in CDC's vs pitt and loss in tissue
and for this we obtained much tissue box
a prostate primary tissue and biopsies
from the metastasis and blood from
patients and the metastasis on the blood
were collected at the same time and we
evaluated the tissue box and prostate
archival TV on the justices for pecan
proteins by IHC are so and we evaluated
attention for Pete engine status by fish
and in the blood we evaluated as Pete
engine status by fish in in 50 feet
using the epic platform and we followed
for the analysis of pten status by fish
who follow the first few steps of ctc
identification and then the same slide
that was used for the identification of
the cassis were then used for the fish
analysis so we remove the cover slip we
washed and restain the stain slide with
fish probes and then we score the fish
on the white blood cells deserved us as
a control and we also asked or the fuge
on the TTC's that will recognize based
on the localization in the first step of
in one of your ex
we evaluated cities in relation on 76
station and we found that eighty-eight
percent of all patients about 69 patient
has more than once with at least 150
feet per milliliter using their dick
platforms and 59 patient seventy-eight
percent of the patient has patients had
three or more 50 cc's per milliliter and
here although we are expressing the
CDC's the CDT enumeration efficacies per
milliliter we counted city system
typically more than 1 million today the
median volume of glass that was
evaluated for citizen CT animation was
3.3 million we found the median CDC
counts of 5 or between five and six
fifty fifty millimeter and the average
fittest account was 16 CBC's per
milliliter in for most of the patients
we have a duplicate blood sample that we
use for ctc enumeration is in the solar
system and here the counts 40pcs on the
social system are done on seven point
five milliliters of class so we
extrapolated the epic counts to 7.5
millimeters for comparison and Viennese
plot we are comparing side-by-side the
50p enumeration in in the epic
sustaining red versus the cell track
system in black and we seek up for those
samples that has the higher number of
DTC's in the in Jacksonville in the last
half of this plot the enumeration in ctc
in from epic and enumeration from
solfege were pretty important now the
generation of more discordant for those
samples that has a lower numbers of 65
cell search and here
immolation on the epic platforms that
need to be higher than the numeration on
digital search platform and there are a
few example using movies so these is the
pay a decision example of this is an
example from sample 5039 that had 167 CT
sister milliliters per 7.5 millimeters
from the epic platform and six CDC's /
10 points i'm in a little on the cell
search platform and here we see that the
official representative example of a CTC
from the epic platform that is psychic
reading for cities of the in this image
in red and here is another example of a
sample 5059 that has 57 PTC's / 7.5
millimeters from the epic platform and
three fifty six percent of 25 minutes on
the cell surface and then again this is
a representative image that shows that
the side of the city seems like you're
getting positive in it it's sustaining
red now we owe in those comfort in those
patient samples that have more than
three two tickets per milliliter we then
tested skip and jump satisfy fish we've
the combination of signage and probes
the Tilton Prague and controls and
trauma accepts improv and define still
major genotypes 8 p-10 normal dinner
tonight when the nuclei had at least one
signal of catan and two murkiness of
pretense ahem if I got bitten long when
the nuclei have at least one female of
the 10 and a single signal of 310 and
homozygous upon loads when the
the nucleus has at least one female of
the 10 and no signals of you can and we
then evaluated the overall population of
city streets and white blood cells from
our patients for the 4 p-10 genotype
sunset cantina types we evaluated over
2500 city fees and over 1,000 white
blood cells I mean the plot here on the
left is the distribution of sequin and
such contino types on city streets with
depend on the y-axis and settle on the
x-axis and on the plot on the right is
the distribution of 15 and certain
genotypes in white blood cells and we
already see that the distribution of
genotypes and white blood cells is very
narrow and it's centered on the white
I've destroyed genotype we see that
ninety-two percent of the office of the
white blood cells has a to publish
oxygen and two copies of substance and
this is the distribution of event of the
genotypes was not blow during sweetie
see for example on what results we never
observed any cell that has complete lots
of different you can do my teen read on
the contrary on city students we have
twelve percent of 350 sees that had that
were showing the phenotype of
homozygosity and loss any fibers pecan
logs was also a lot more frequent in
CDC's and in white blood cells and was
frequently accompanied by also an
increased number of steps and signaling
and overall the number of such
sentiments was higher in in cities which
turning white blood cells in CDC's
twenty-five percent of all tpc had will
mark them here has 34 more poppy
signature acceptance up to 14 penis
obstruction in acidity and why does
so sorry i'll go back here on on white
blood cells we found only one point four
percent of all the white blood cells
that have three copies of substance that
never know that that and the images here
on the bottom shows show representative
cases of this phenotype on the upper
panel we see images of
immunofluorescence with cytokeratin in
red indicated on marketing the city fees
and cd45 in fingering on the panel on
the on the Dozen final whiskey images of
fish with keaton showed in red and
second-degree and we can see in the
first two tunnels that the two
sitagliptin phosphate asuka seeds have a
no signals of sittin so those are those
books images represent homozygous cute
and lost in Syracuse the 3-meter images
showed CTC Ian characterized by the way
chocolatey in the upper tunnels and
showing only one copy of Susan on the
citizens and the last two panels
represent cells that have two more
copies of students so no deletion of
pecan so in general what this
distribution show that is that in the
CDC's they seem to be an increased
slowly and increased and an increased
frequency of sleep and lock in
comparison to white blood cells now we
also looked at the distribution of p10
genotypes with limitations so this this
plot here represents is each column in
this plot represents a single patient
and the percentage of disease that have
homozygous we can loss is colorful even
read the percentage of city sees that
showed only one single of pretend
hemizygous attend loss is represented in
yellow
and the percentage of CDC's with no pit
in Los a representation green and we
already see that in some of these in
many of these patients there was a
mixture of feet and genotypes for
example a patient 4037 had a small
percentage of city series that had no no
edition of the 10 about thirty percent
of GD fees that has or a single copy of
pretend and about sixty percent of
statistics that have no pockets of
betaine homozygous deletion of 210 now
we're in spite of this heterogeneity we
were able to to classify the tension in
two distinct or discrete categories or
homozygous floats and Tiger claws and no
division of 10 based on an algorithm for
fittin status classification is
impatient that was based on the rate of
false positives pitch and loss in white
blood cells only stratification took
into consideration the number of CDC's
and the frequency of city sees with
homozygous loss of pten hanif I got lots
of return or no deletion of students and
you can find more information about this
algorithm that was developed by our team
education in the paper this paper that
if I forgot to mention before it was
publishing in british journal of cancer
last year so so as we use English the
classification we found that about that
twenty-seven percent of the patients
showed homozygous written laws and
fifteen percent of the patients showed
his eye of speed and loss overall
forty-two percent of the patient shows
lots of titanium CDC now we then
compared the status of p10 in city seat
versus the status of
and in tissues using fish and in this
case we're comparing two fresh tissue
and what we see is that for all those
patients that have homozygous peak and
lost in sin Institute's we have
consistent homozygous speak and loss in
the fresh tissue the concordance in the
group that had him Cyrus loss in ntpc
was not as strong we don't need to love
this fixation showing any sign of law
students education and there were three
cases that were up over discordant the
three pages together I'm going to show
to point to these cases now that were
homozygous loss in fresh tissue but we
didn't find any CDC with homozygous loss
in the in the blood and we looked at a
number large number of of city sees in
these patients 15 18 and 20 through city
streets but there were no cases of
homicide alone now here are some
examples of patients that have
concordant didn't stab using tissue
sanity in archival TV and fresh
schedules and incidences in the upper
panel will see a patient sample
connotation that had homicidal script
and lost in the archives few more
tissues they shall we chose will be
found homo cycle keeping locked in the
fresh tumor tissue and concordance
homozygous pit and loss in CDC's in the
middle panel is images from turn to turn
analysis of the patient that had known
t10 loss notes teeth and deletions in
archival tumor tissue but the pittance
of shifted to death homicidal is
convicted of homicide essentially 50
feet and loss in the French team or
tissue and a concordance mixture of
homozygous and heavy sigh oh sweet and
lawful citizens and in the bottom panel
with the examples of a patient that no
and deletion in dec I'd tumor no pretend
deletion in the fresh tumor and no t10
dilution in DC DC and we try to quantify
these comparisons in the tables here in
this slide on the table on the left to
the comparison between city fees and
fresh by treating metastatic biopsies in
38 match patients that have successful
Pete and status tested in ttc standing
in the tissue we see that 32 of the
circulate stations eighty-four percent
of the patients have overall concept
concordance and the this table shows
that the positive predictive value from
this comparison seventy-nine percent
with high sensitivity and specificity
with eighty eight percent specificity
and seventy-nine percent of sensitivity
on the table on the right is a
comparison between city season and
archive file with the archives primary
diet in from here from 39 much patience
24 were concordant sixty-two percent
work importance and the values of
positive predictive value specificity
and sensitivity were lower than those
for the comparison between cities and
fresh file which suggests that the city
sees are providing as a snapshot of the
pigeon status in the most current
villages now we also compared to Britain
back to the pit and gene status ncpc's
with the treatin protein status in
tissue that was evaluated by IHC and
here on the after panel of this image we
see an example of rotation that had
homicidal design loss in CDC's and that
had a concordance loss of speech and
expression by IHC in the bone marrow
biopsy and in the bottom panel is an
example of a patient that has no
division of defense
by fixing to disease and high expression
of beaten protein by ifc in the world
autobiography and on the plot on the
right we again are comparing the seat
the pittance which results from city
sees with the pit and protein results by
IHC that are quantified as as the
weighted age score and we can see that
all the front from the 17 patients that
has homicide before hemizygous pete and
loss introduces all those patients had
very low or no expression of feet and
protein by IHC in the metastatic tissue
and and from the patient the there are
24 patients and apologize for having the
circle block sided that deserves 24
patients that have no deletion of p10 in
ptc the majority of them have a highly
expressional or positive expression of
pre-planning protein in the official the
word six patients that has no expression
of forbidden protein in the tissue and
this could be no cases of epigenetic
free genetic silencing or publication so
these observations indicate that the
piquant status in 56 also correlates
with a pittance protein status in tissue
now in addition to our analysis of the
whole molecular analysis of fittin to
tangent satisfies function to disease we
analyzed the expression of a are and
localization of the Yaran CPC and here
are three examples of expression and
localization of androgen receptor in the
first case in the upper panel we see a
CTC recycle keratin positive cd45 [ __ ]
and where they are expression is
exclusively localizing the nuclei in the
middle panel is the ucf city see again
psychokinetic positive it's 345 negative
and i er expression appears to be
excluded from the nuclei in the recall
excited last with localization singing
the third panel we see an example of a
city see that has a better expression
both in the nuclei are in the cytosol
and we were able to test we are
expression and localization in the
subset of the patients in our in our
study and we compare the expression of
the yard with Pete and fish status in
this plot each column represents
location and in update and a niche dot
is the secrecy and the city sees are
color-coded for the pigeon status so the
dots in great representative sees that
has homicidal student loss with Austin
yellow represents city sees that have
semi driver season loss and adult in
gray rcbc with no relation of p.m. and
on the y-axis we have we are indicating
the levels of a yard expression the
intensity based on on signal intensity
and we can already see that there is
heterogeneity over your expression
reading patients so for force majority
of his patients error expression goes
from low to high range we also don't do
it in addition to the heterogeneity
within patients we don't see any
particular concordance for correlation
between AR expression and p10 status for
example if we look at patient 5 will try
school all the TTC's and more fiber
cloths and i er expression goes from low
to the highest levels and by comparison
patient 5085 has also
high-to-low expressions of a yard in the
petition with all TTP's or almost all
statistics are have no dilution of pecan
and finally we looked at the
localization of a yar and again we
couldn't see any confidence between
localization and Putin status with many
of the patients that has homozygous
spittin launching TTC's has a yard
localized to the nuclei or to the
cytosol or to a combination so finally
all the patients that will force so all
the patients that will tested for Pete
institutions if she didn't belong to a
single clinical trial but the most of
them have been treated with a beer at
Paranal and early tonight and all of
them were followed for survival if we
divided attention between those that had
Pete and loss even CDC's either a
homicidal for hemizygous they were
grouped together and they were called
Pete and loss in indicated with the red
line versus patients that had no
division of pecans indicated by this
driving that line we see that there is a
significant association between Pete and
loss and worse survival with the median
overall survival for the Peter lost
population of seven months versus 12
months middle or will survive a median
overall survival for no pretense
position now in the neurologist analysis
we found that Pete and law also ethics
if account hi Latin dehydrogenation
visual diseases all associated with
words overall survival so this this
observation suggests that the analysis
of the assessment of peace and loss
could be a valuable biomarker of
resistance to
or hormonal treatment and perhaps
service with positive biomarkers for
selection in combination therapies with
a gay teen militant and we are now using
this assessment of p10 union city sees
in a Facebook study of inter task for
even a guillotine to be good in
metastatic castration-resistant prostate
cancer patients that has progressed
after a prior to that therapy with us at
Axl's here that we enroll 240 patients
into three arms to arms of a belated on
in combination with the akt inhibitor in
different doses and a control arm with a
veteran alone the primary outcome
measures is CSS invitations and in
patients with cheat and loss at the
charging by IHC and at exploratory
measurement we are testing the
correlation of different status entities
will occur we represent status in tissue
and with clinical outcomes measures so
as a conclusion to our study
demonstrated the utility of ctc
characterization 4 p-10 status in
assertion resistant prostate cancer
patients we use the epic scientists
platform for the analysis ventricular
analysis of citizens and we found that
we found more than more than 30 more CPC
spur milliliters in seventy-eight
percent of the patients we developed an
essay 4 p-10 status in quickly seized by
fish and we found that pigeon status
entities is correlated well with bitten
status in fresh tissues from
castration-resistant prostate cancer
patients and we found that peach and
loss was associated with words overall
survival since patients that were
treated with hormone therapy and we are
currently again looking at the ethan
status intricacies in a face to win an
ongoing phase 2 trial of a negative
editor in metastatic cancer
metastatic prostate cancer patient and
with this I want to first acknowledge
this was a collaboration it's a broad
collaboration between Genentech the
images of cancer research and the Royal
Marsden Hospital in the UK and epic
sciences and again I want to acknowledge
everybody from the group of this canoe
so Genentech the group of Johan de Bono
as I see our and Rakim as epic and and I
will be happy to to get questions thank
you doctor for bringing that excellent
presentation to us before we get to our
question and answers I'd like to point
out to our audience that a whole will be
appearing clear screen if you could take
a moment to give us some feedback we
would sure appreciate it now to ask your
questions questions can be sent via the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we'll get to as
many of your questions as we can we
don't get your question today we will
follow up with you and our first
question comes from our attendees and
they ask our patients classified as both
a cho and HC loss detective in the
sample okay so so this is very
unquestioned because as I mentioned as i
showed in some of our slides there was a
mixture of different genotypes reading
every patient so they wish there was
some heterogeneity with this patient
with mixtures of CDC's that were
homozygous loss with CDC's and wash and
tigers lost now our classification
system for bitten status in patients
with a hierarchical classification first
positions are classified based on the
significance presence of homicidal flow
of secrecy and
and they were classified based on the
significant presence of semi fibers loss
sweetie series and the rationale for
this hierarchical classification was
that we expected that homicidal Flores
will eliminate all weekend protein
expression and have a more significant
clinical effect and so so we decided
that if the patient has significant
presence of homozygous love statistics
we will classify the patient as that of
homicide applause thank you our next
question how would it cut offs 4 p-10
analysis in tissue and CTCs established
the the cutoff for those fat tissue and
cities for people not indifferent
succeed where established based on the
rate of false positives between normal
tissue or in in white blood cells the
normal tissue we tested 542 with a big
five normal prostate tissues for the
four feet and fish and we capture a we
clear away with in calculating the
median plus three standard deviations of
the percentage of nuclei that has peaked
and loss and these led us to a cutter
for thirty percent 14 homozygous loss
unfortunate I a flaw in our city sees
the cutoff of established based on the
rate of false positive feet and loss in
white blood cells and this was done both
for white glossy white blood cells that
were present in the patient sample and
white blood cells wrong from a normal
healthy donors and the numbers were very
similar for work ourselves from donors
and for patient again as I mentioned
during the talk the classification start
took into account the number of
and the percentage of the different
genotypes of homicide offense I go son
no deletions that were found in this
sample and again I would like to refer
you to the classification rules that are
very detailed in the supplemental table
in our paper thank you we have another
question how much blood is needed and
what kind of tools are used how do you
convert a TC per milliliter from epic to
ctc / seven point five milliliters to
compare with cell search platform why
won't sell search report ctc per
milliliter so I said to question the
first question is how which which to
reduce for the cells for the epic system
will you subtract you that are
commercially available to you that allow
for the sterilization of your blood for
for several days the second questions
about the immolation and the different
organizations use on the shelter system
on an epic the social system is is
counting city sees in 7.5 millimeters
and the North they are normalized the
number of pieces that are are found they
are normalized to the 7.5 millimeters
there is no extrapolation now and this
is the way the system is commercially
available and is set up now for the epic
system the volumes of black may vary
from patient to patient because the way
they are plated is by standardizing the
number of mutated cells that are slated
if every slide gates about 3 million
nucleated cells so the volumes can vary
a little bit and that's why we are
normalizing them to one milliliter I
think I might have mentioned during the
chocolate wave median volume that is
tested in this study for ctc
enumerations 3.3 million acres but the
volume provided from I think one
milliliter to seven or eight militants
thank you Evanescence an attendee asks
what is the difference between single
cell fusion and double cell fusion I'm
not quite sure what the question is
referring to if we can clarify what this
refers to don't thank us yeah I I think
we can have somebody follow up and in
the meantime move on to our next
question and then the ndf one would p10
be lost in white blood cell count well
we we don't normally expect feet and
loss in white blood cells and as you saw
in the overall distribution of people
and second genotype in white blood cells
we never saw any case of homozygous feet
and lost in white blood cells we did see
some cases where there was came in sight
of chicken looks and this could be a
technical issue that one of the signals
was lost from you know from from the
cell because of taxation issue or
staining issue I I wouldn't expect the
white best eaten we lost because of any
you know biological reason I would
expect that this is most great technical
thank you we do have another question
from an attendee what was the
concordance between fresh tissue and
archival also what was the concordance
between the static and primary in terms
of p10 law okay yes and I think I can go
back to one of the slide is it is it
possible for me to go back to the slides
now you have to give us okay so let me
see I didn't show that during yeah I
didn't show that during the tub but I
anticipated this question so i have here
an extra slide that shows this because
listen between our type issues and fresh
tissue while tight issue on on the left
and fresh tissue on the top of this
table and receded from 36 patients that
had merged archives and fresh tissue
with with successful Pete and fish
analysis in both we have 24 that that
that work important so this would be
about how much 60-something person
concurrent so there is some discordant
in the English issues so they withdrew
the evolution of legacy so perhaps
because of heterogeneity of Philippe's
and we see that from the discordant
patient 9 has where Pete and deleted in
the archive tissue and evolved to the
non deletion of season on the fresh
viously and three were non deleted in
the archives biopsy and evolved through
a p10 deletion in the fresh biopsy and
an internal and here on the right
direction interesting note that from
those patients that were discordant 12-4
from the 12 patients that were recorded
between archived and fresh biopsy at 10
of them had didn't status entities that
was concordant through the fresh
gaieties and I hope this answers the
question of the question you def fact
okay we have another question with a
relatively high number of gains of cep
10 that you saw in some of the CTC
results also observed in the tumor
tissue fish studies of cep 10 in the
same patient hmm that's a good question
and I don't think we observed that high
level sets then gain in the tissue the
teaching the tissue has some differences
with the city to the fish indicating
see for example in city speech we have
learned more hemizygous loss than what
we had observed in the tissue now with
respect for Seed Sceptile I think I
believe that we never observed 14
signals you know for taking signals of
them the way we did observe in CDC's but
I i apologize i should go back to our no
specific quantification in teaching when
I will be happy to to to follow up on
this question thank you doctor we do
have time for one last question with the
fish son with ctc or tissues and how do
they compare this was done both in city
fees and in tissue and the comparison
and we I can go back to the slide and
that that should show the comparison oh
no you're right come here
so here is the comparison of our feet
and fishing she keeps mentioning tissue
I mean in a normal tissue and as I
mentioned the the forum Osiris lot of
the concordance was pretty good for the
cases of homicidal claws the concordance
was not so good and I think the best
quantification will be here in these
tables where we have shitty feeds on the
left and tissue and the upper only only
offered current and here for the
comparison between traditional fresh
tissue the positive predictive value for
seventy nine percent and which was done
on 38 stage match patients and the
comparison between city season and the
archives issue that was a non 36-39 much
patience was gave us a positive
predictive value of sixty-nine percent
right so yes so basically to finish this
question we are sweet can we can do we
can we can assess fish in citizens and
tissues they advantage of DTC's because
we can perhaps get a more updated result
of updated view of the of the student
status when in a statistics are
available which happened in our case in
seventy-eight percent of the cases thank
you doctor is our questions finished I
just thank God Boozman again for her
excellent presentation dr. do you have
any final comments for our audience on
this issue I basically the main comment
here is that we I think exploring three
td's of electric fireplaces has been you
know has been very illuminating the fact
that we had such a good component
between the status of p10 in tissue and
in city sees it is also encouraging and
I think we are all excited in
anticipation to the results of the
faithful trial of
akt inhibitor to know first what is it
important weed official in a clinical
trial setting which might be different
from the setting of our study and second
what is the concordance with a clinical
result thank you again dr. Wilson I'd
also like to thank our sponsor epic
science from making it possible to bring
this educational web seminar to you
today the webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through July of 2016
attendees will receive an email from us
alerting you when it's available on
demand and posted on libraries calm you
are welcome to forward this announcement
to any colleagues who aren't able to
join us for today's live broadcast thank
you again for logging on and
participating we hope to see you next
time